peu
on
[Musique]
daniel maugard 26 ans maman d'une petite
fille de deux ans et demi elle habite
marseille
apparemment c'est une femme comme les
autres elle est inspecteur de police
comme elle il y en a 250 en france une
centaine sont détachés dans différents
services de police comme les
renseignements généraux et la dst 150
sont affectés à la brigade des mineurs
leur rôle est avant tout de freiner
l'escaladé de la délinquance de protéger
l'enfant et l'adolescent et pour chaque
cas d'essayer de trouver une solution
est-ce que tu étais avec ton copain ce
jour là qu'est ce qu'il était avec toi
normes mien et je vois également que tu
as déjà fait un séjour au bo med séjour
de dix jours
alors écoute quand même il faut il faut
que tu sois extrême que tu fasse très
attention maintenant parce que tu as 14
ans beaucoup de jeunes me tutoie et je
n'ai pas l'impression que l'on me
considère comme un policier mais de
toute façon je pense que sur le plan
humain et sur le plan des confidences et
c'est aussi bon parce que ils ont
tellement l'habitude des policiers
qu'ils connaissent surtout de réputation
qu'ils sont dans le fond ils sont ravis
de voir quelqu'un qui leur parle
simplement et qui essaie de les
comprendre
je veux m'expliquer fois qu'un homme qui
préfère toi chauffer avant tout elles
sont policiers et surtout inspecteurs
différents services de la police
la brigade criminelle la brigade des
moeurs la brigade antigang demande leur
concours pour certaines opérations dans
ces cas là elle court exactement les
mêmes risques que les hommes
[Musique]
tu de travestir quel est ton prénom à
leur étant sûrement aller quel âge as-tu
nous sommes quand même toujours protégé
dans la mesure où un inspecteur de
police energy jamais elle est toujours
ce à plusieurs
nous en avons comme excuse ça marche
est ce qu'il existe une grande
différence entre l'inspecteur hommes et
à l'inspecteur fabre absolument aucune
étant donné que nous sommes un jeune de
police eux tous les deux nous sommes
recrutés selon le new passant le même
concours nouveau suivant le même message
nous avons des
prérogatives nous pouvons faire des
arrestations les sommes dues nous sommes
assez remonté quelquefois il m'arrive
d'avoir un petit pincement au coeur
quand elle s'en va c'est un sentiment
bien naturel mais qu'est ce que vous
voulez nous avons pris le risque puisque
nous l'avons décidé ensemble n'est ce
pas regarder cette scène il est deux
heures du matin l'inspecteur maugard est
en service
j'étais en train de faire une planque et
je servais da par un maître chanteur qui
fixe est ici des rendez-vous à une jeune
femme l'en but de lui soutirer de
l'argent contre des photos qui auraient
pu la compromettre et le clochard que le
genre que la sur le vent était
l'inspecteur qui me couvre est bon mais
c'est un échec parce qu'il n'est pas
venu et je sais ça fait une heure que
j'ai hâte que j'attends pour éviter
parce que vous n'avez pas dans ces cas
là oui il star oui parce qu'on ne sait
jamais sur qui on peut tomber
250 femmes sont à specter de police en
france aucune d'entre elle ne peut
encore accéder au concours de
commissaire mais d'ici à 1975
ce concours pourrait bien leur être
ouvert
[Musique]